I said I was going to use his result
right this pair of results that you did
I hope you've gotten some of the same
for Peter and cause for theta if you
were with so forth in your life but I
have cosines flying around yeah and I
can't get rid of that's okay that's okay
the reason why you can't get rid of them
is if you've done this expansion right
yeah
uh yeah well you will get some double
angles and you can't just say I mean
it's a bit of a this is already looking
at before um you can't say this but
there's nothing profound about that
because we already knew that just from
double angle formula
it's just double double angle formula
okay however just it's just we're
stating that when you do this binomial
expansion because of the cosine is going
up at this rate and the site's code
science knowing sorry all the way around
the cosine is going down at this rate
and the sine is going up at this rate
you're always going to get it odd
multiple of some clients sines or
cosines in one of the extensions so you
will never get them to be able to get
rid of all of them because you can only
get rid of um even multiples of them by
using the fact the coordinate then okay
so you should have that result if you
want let me have a look at it now
somebody's gonna like a coma he's how we
going to use this pair of results that
we are establishment for is pair triple
angles here's a question and again just
like I was illustrating more broadly
we'd like why do we even go into complex
numbers like this is just angles this is
just treat we don't need complex on the
sport well no but when you when you use
complex on this when you open yourself
up to that well Wow is the results just
kind of very easily come out of the
question here is an example where look
at this time right what does this have
anything to do with trig you don't need
trig to solve this but if you open
yourself up to using that tool the
answer comes out quite elegantly so
let's give this a go
firstly it says Express 10 theta into
sorry 10 3 theta in terms of tan theta
now no he needs to what will be your
first line tan 3 theta is the sign for
theta on cos 3 theta let's write that
down
excuse me okay now we've seen this kind
of thing before right
sometimes you've been um you've been
handed equations that you need to solve
the quadratic in terms of a trig
function like this right like three sine
squared theta plus sine theta minus 2
equals zero so you've seen these guys
before right but you remember as well
sometimes you see ones with it's not
just in terms of sines or just in terms
of cosines it's in terms of like a mix
of sines and cosines what did you get
those do you remember if I gave you
something like this we should do it
something like that actually I don't
want that one we get zero right when
this is a mix of sine and cosines you
can't simply state it as a quadratic
sibling sine or sibling cosine so you
have to do a division right do I need a
cross squared over there I think I'm
nice anyway I just made that example of
what you would do is you would divide by
some ratio of cos cos or cos squared or
cubed in order to turn all of your turns
into tens or something related that so
in this case you divide everything by
cos square right that would turn the
first term once you divide that into
divide that by cos square you get three
tan square when you do by the middle
term by a COS square that cause that's
already there we'll go you have one at
the bottom which will give you ten and
then you just get minus one over here
aha quadratic in ten okay now here you
have all this identical situation I have
a mix of sines and cosines I know I want
to get everything in terms of tans so
what Rand are you going to pull out the
Hat what would you like to suggest that
I do with this fraction
so over on the right hand side of the
board I divided by cos squared why did I
choose closed square I was looking at
the degree wasn't I was looking the
degree the highest power the two days
right
in order to overcome that the exact
thing you divide by is the corresponding
power now over here I have um cubes
flying around okay so therefore that's
what I have to get rid of yes so for
example up on the numerator having
divided by cos cubed what does this term
tell you to well
well I've got the sine divided by one of
the cosine so I will turn it to tan
that's fine but then there are still two
cos squares two / right so I'll be
dividing by cos squared what's that
that's a reciprocal what's the
reciprocal of cos it's SEC so I have SEC
squared there right
hmm now I haven't looked at my
identities for a while let's just keep
going and see how far we can get sine
cubed on clothes cute right that's just
gonna be take it okay what happens on
the denominator okay I've just got that
number there and then again here I've
got okay so who remembers their
Pythagorean identity for this
okay so excuse me
so full disclosure I said this before
right I don't I don't remember but it
doesn't matter because I remember the
easy one and then you get everything
else from there how do I get a play
exactly the same trick that's in terms
of sines and cosines right what do I do
in on again in terms of tens I divide by
square that's going to turn this into
two it's where that's going to turn that
into one and that's gonna turn that into
it okay so now I know I can get rid of
these fairly easily I think let's just
quickly do it so on the top I've already
got a ten meter and this is going to
turn into it don't post a sweat on the
denominator I have another SEC squared
to replace and now I just have to do
some algebra right just got a credit
limit
so let's see here but three ten feet are
hanging out the front I've got three 10
cubed minus 4 10 cubed which is minus
one tank yeah did I do it right yeah
yeah denominator tell me what to do 4
minus 3 years and then minus 3/10 width
ah take 3 feet up in terms of okay now
you've got that result now that's pretty
cool by the way
like it does bear familiarity and
resemblance with the 10th to theta
result right like it it's not completely
outside the realm of whoa that looks
crazy okay how are we gonna use it to
solve this polynomial